is it really true like one of the very
quick tips i tell people is put a
question mark at the end of everything
that you hear in your head just put a
question up
you're a [ __ ] idiot you're a [ __ ]
idiot
[Laughter]
i mean it might be a yes but
what do you describe what you do for
work how do you describe it
um well i mean the moniker that i've
commonly
become known as is the mind architect um
in terms of what does that mean my main
product
i tell people is freedom uh really
liberating people from the constraints
of uh particularly their subconscious
mind so the primal patterns that have
us as human beings suffer in any way i
uh emancipate people from that mental
prison
why is the subconscious so important
with that given the fact that
a lot of people see their suffering
coming from external factors or internal
obvious triggers
where does the subconscious fit into
this um
it's sort of the quintessential part of
the iceberg that you can't see
you know we've all seen those memes a
million times as it relates to business
and whatever it is like you know you can
just see the tip that's um
someone's persona as we know them
perhaps but
until you get to the deepest seated
programming that really was
created during the formative years of
our childhood and
these these are the constraints that we
function within
and so if you really want to make any
kind of lasting change in your life or
any dramatic change and you've got to be
able to access
what are the parameters that a human
being currently functions
in versus sort of just changing the the
superficial behaviors which a lot of
people
you know are constantly trying to do and
then they wonder why they revert back to
old habits
how much or how important is our
subconscious
in between the two we've got the
external factors is it that iceberg
analogy do you think that
what we see and what we perceive is only
a small amount of what causes suffering
or happiness
i mean the immediate answer is yes um
i mean it's important uh as important as
the foundations of a house
you know you could say well you know i
really like this particular tap
you know it's like gorgeous and it's
gold-plated and
like okay that's awesome but like you
know
where does that go in your master
bathroom and that's part
of a five six thousand square foot home
and all of it doesn't mean
jack unless you've got a solid
foundation you know if you built a
foundation for a house that can only
hold
a 2 000 square foot building then you
can
dream and aspire as much as you want for
this beautiful
sprawling mansion but it's not going to
work right so that's the equivalent in
terms of construction but that's
someone's life they want to make money
they want to have a beautiful
relationship they want to be in great
shape
they want to live for a long long you
know all of the things that people dream
and aspire to
can't happen if you're functioning
within a foundation
aka your subconscious that won't permit
it won't
make space for it what does it mean to
have a conversation or to interact with
something
which by its very definition is below
the threshold of our unconsciousness
we're talking about trying to interact
with something which is purpose-built
to not be noticeable yeah so
what what does it mean to have a
conversation with that how do you even
begin
yeah oh it is no well you have to you
have to talk to peter crone
obviously that's why you're here
um so yes it gets a bit slippery and
it's why i
uh why i use the term reverse engineer
so
where there's smoke you know where
there's fire right like so there's an
implication so the way that i work
certainly is when somebody does work
with me an athlete an entertainer
businessman whoever it might be whatever
it is that they believe they're dealing
with they're to be able to present their
story their scenarios their symptoms
and for me that reveals okay if you
experience
depression anxiety addiction
relationship problems financial problems
an ongoing disease some sort of chronic
condition
then it's revelatory to me meaning i'm
able to go oh okay if you deal with this
particular superficial
situation then that tells me a lot about
what must be beneath the surface
so it's a bit of a i'd say it's actually
a lot of a gift but it's also
it is difficult for the individual to be
able to just
access their own subconscious because
it's sort of behind the eyes literally
and figuratively
right so it takes somebody who's willing
either to
get reflection from somebody who knows
how to listen in a powerful way
or to be able to sit still long enough
to
really inquire like through meditation
um as one example what must i
believe about myself at the deepest
level that has me think feel and behave
in a certain way that elicits these
results versus just trying to change
behavior most people function in the
world of action right you go and see a
specialist or an expert they're like oh
you do this do that
shouldn't do that stop it's all in the
realm of behavior
so that's maybe going to make some sort
of transitory difference but it's not
going to be long lasting if you haven't
changed the fundamental code in the way
that you
view yourself because you're still
eventually going to have the same
thoughts
that lead to the same feelings that then
will create automatically actions
the habits and the consequential results
so
you've got to go to the center of who
you are as a being
if you want to make any kind of long
lasting
profound change in your life so that's
what it looks like is it's slippery it's
difficult it takes a lot of
intuition and invariably it takes
reflection you know this is why i think
relationships are beautiful because
you may not be going to see a peter
crone or you know a
a therapist or someone who's worth their
salt but you know you might have a
girlfriend or a boyfriend or a husband
or a wife or a mother-in-law
and they trigger the [ __ ] out of you
well there's your therapist
you know it's like they pissed me off
they upset me
you know and okay great well then that's
just helping you to see
where is your foundation to use the
metaphor i gave earlier
a little bit shaky where are you unable
to be with the circumstances of life
without getting upset
that's the revelation process so usually
most people don't want to look at it as
themselves
no it really is my mother mother-in-law
if you met her you would agree
yeah she's a [ __ ] everyone around her
says that she's a [ __ ]
yeah and you've got all the evidence to
confirm okay great well then you're
stuck
because you're right about the fact that
you're a victim of circumstance and
that's one of the most powerless places
for people to be
so life will continue to help you to see
what's going on in your subconscious is
just
are you paying attention
it's obvious to me sometimes you you see
people or you meet people
and they have a it's like a flavor
to that imbues all of the things that
they do
all of the different interactions
whether they be in a relationship
whether they be at work
whether it's to do with their fitness
their health their happiness
whatever it might be everything kind of
has the same
tenor you know it's like all
on the same sort of frequency somehow
everything's a bit
it's a little bit passive aggressive or
it's a little bit kind of overly
defensive or it's a little bit
vulnerable or it's a little bit
they don't take stuff seriously and it
always seems to happen across a lot and
the there is a unifying thread that
brings all of that together i'm going to
guess that
that is these unknown unknowns
that sit in the subconscious yeah it's
you know if you're if you're sitting in
a in a world a construct
then it's kind of like it doesn't matter
what you do
who you're with what you wear what you
say everything is being informed by that
fundamental construct
right so right now for example we're all
on planet earth you know i don't know
how big your audience is i'm assuming
it's not beyond the globe but maybe it
is
welcome to those who are listening first
intergalactic podcast yeah precisely
yeah
but i'm gonna guess that for the most
part people are on planet earth
somewhere and one of the constructs that
we all fall prey to
that we all have to abide by the laws of
physics is called gravity
doesn't matter if you're in the uk or
here in the states or you're in iceland
or timbuktu or australia
if you stand on a wall don't you know
don't go on a very high wall but if you
go on a two
three foot wall and you jump you know
you're gonna
go down right hence why i don't want
people to be on a massive ball
no we don't want any injuries on this
inter galactica podcast
but anyway the point is that is a
construct that we function within
and it doesn't matter where you go
that's going to be the case
right that you're going to be able to
jump to a certain degree but you're
always going to come back down so
likewise in somebody's subconscious
whatever it is your particular flavor to
you said you know there's this sort of
certain quality that is consistent in
people's behavior
it's it's because they're being informed
by the same construct
for them you know for someone it might
be the world of
they don't feel like they're good enough
you know which everyone can relate to so
in their particular way of interacting
in relationships in the workplace in
their home in their body
there's this undercurrent of
perfectionism you know you know
dave and he can't like ever kind of
relax you know it's like he's always got
to have his [ __ ] together
and he's always well put together and
you know he can't really tell you that
things didn't go well because that would
look bad and you know he's being
informed by the fact that at the deeper
level
he doesn't feel good enough and so
compensatory
like mechanism the way that he's learned
to protect himself and survive is to
become a perfectionist
right um so that's again where we could
reverse engineer you see somewhat
superficial behaviors the way that they
consistently get the same results and
then it will reveal
ah okay i can see that at a young age
because his brother got more attention
was a better athlete or was more
successful in the school play
you know or had greater academic results
than dave relative to his older brother
felt somewhat inadequate and he made
that mean that he wasn't good enough and
then he developed his survival
mechanisms right
so um that's you know that's what
everyone's dealing with they've got
their own
flavor of their personality and even the
word persona right and greek
relates to when they were doing plays
they would wear a mask
and use this bull horn to speak through
as actors and that was called the
persona it was a mask
and even though you know we're where you
see there's persons
on the planet like that persona is
something really that i'm
i'm revealing for somebody in the most
compassionate loving way is nothing
wrong with it but it is going to be an
obstacle potentially to the things that
you want to create in your life and if i
can
bring light to the constraints so that
you can step outside of them then you
have a bigger bandwidth you become more
expanded and you have a greater life
so if you're into that kind of stuff i
like the analogy
of it being your own personal laws of
physics
i think that's really really cool that
you have certain
things and you could look at somebody
else and they're a different universe in
their universe perhaps the laws of
physics actually manifest a little bit
differently
and that could be the way that they deal
with setbacks
and in your physical universe the way
that your substrate the source code
within your subconscious is written that
you have
this program if bad thing happens run
program
shityourpants.exe or whatever it might
be um yeah but for this other person
he deals with it fine or she deals with
it fine how come that happens
yeah yeah and it's at that level that we
can really say there's no such thing as
choice
it's uh trigger and response trigger and
response right so
when you become increasingly aware of
your code
of your deep-seated programs now we
could say that there's
a semblance of responsibility right
which is um access to
being a powerful human being so oh if i
know
the mechanisms that run me by virtue of
how i've been conditioned over time
then i have a choice if i'm in the
program there's no choice it's just
literally external stimulus internal
reaction
and we see this you know people in
traffic someone cuts you off it's like
hey you [ __ ] idiot you know it's like
that that's not that's not a choice
response that is purely automated
and it can lead to a lot of you know
blood and
scuffed fists and whatever you know but
it's if you start to go wow
i'm under the impression that like a
piece of metal and plastic with a human
being in it
driving that i don't even know who they
are that reaction is saying that i'm
giving them power over my emotional
state now when you break it down it's
like it's completely nonsensical i don't
even know who that person is
and i'm saying they are in charge of my
internal wellness
right and when you see that it's like
well why would
why would i give that person so much
command
over my emotional well-being well you
wouldn't if you're like a rational
intelligent like responsible human being
and that starts to give that
idea of self-responsibility of like okay
that person coming in front of me in the
traffic adds maybe
like one to two seconds in my day
but i watch crap tv for three hours a
night like
you know it's like really is that really
going to change the fact that i'm not a
multi-millionaire
with a six-pack and dating a supermodel
or whatever that person wants like
no i mean you start to go oh hang on a
minute i'm just a victim
of my own conditioning not even a victim
of circumstance i'm a victim of my own
programming that i'm oblivious to
in becoming a powerful human being is to
reveal the programming that i have by
virtue of my childhood which is no
slight and parents
it's not like mum and dad's fault
they're doing the best they can within
their programming
so we get out of the blame game too and
go oh hang on there's this sentient
being a soul who's incarnated
i've taken on this code and perhaps we
could say that my opportunity is to
reveal the code and transcend it so that
i
step into a much broader expanded
version myself
and consequently great things show up in
my life boom
end of story
[Laughter]
it's interesting it's interesting
thinking about
just how much deprogramming we can do is
there a state where you can get to where
you've dissolved so much subconscious
that it's actually a disadvantage not
that i'm aware of
you think that most people just have
more to do well i
i don't know how your work and your
vision of the subconscious maps on to
sort of dissolving of the ego
and letting go etc but yeah i can
imagine a world
within which people became so
enlightened or they became so detached
from their subconscious and what their
actual internal programming is supposed
to do for instance
your body keeps you breathing all the
time you don't consciously have to think
about that it is a subconscious action
that keeps that going and there's a lot
of wisdom inherent just
in the way that we are now a lot of that
also kind of
manifests in a malignant or a not
non-adaptive non-effective manner but
there's also there's also certain things
you put your hand in a fire you don't
really actually need to be taught
not to do it your body is able to react
in that sort of a way
i'm aware that that's slightly less
cognitive and cerebral and a little bit
more sort of
within the body that's more embodied but
still i wonder whether there is
too far it would appear that you haven't
found someone that's pushed it too far
yet
no because again like i said earlier
when i was speaking specifically about
the subconscious i didn't say we're
getting rid of
everything that's part of your
subconscious like being able to get out
of bed in the morning and walk
over to the toilet and you know take a
leak or then go to the
kitchen and get a glass of water you
know that's part of your subconscious
yeah when if you remember which most
people won't but if they're a parent
they certainly see it
which is as a three-month-old they can't
do that
right so part of the habituation of what
it means to be
a human and certainly an adult or after
we get to about the age of two and we
have functions like
walking running balance that's
great aspects of the programming of the
subconscious but what i said is we want
to remove the constraints not like
remove every piece of programming that
you've ever downloaded and developed
no that would uh that probably wouldn't
look pretty um
so it's really specifically to what i
would consider these primal pieces of
code that are all in the realm of
survival that are
they they're fundamentally based in fear
right that's the
they're the constraints of the
subconscious that i'm reconciling and
dissolving for people
like i love the fact that you know how
to ride a bike or you can ride a
motorcycle at speed around the corner
like you know
good for you but if you do it from a
perspective of i
am trying to impress my girlfriend on
the back because i'm scared that no one
loves me
yeah you know that might not end well
right so
you know like that goes back to our mate
dave you know he's trying to show off
all the time
what are the most then he gets all the
daves out dave yeah every every dave's
pissing himself at the moment um
what are some of the most common
patterns or constraints
that you encounter in people's
subconscious then have you got like a
top of the pops
top three or something top ten i go it's
my book you know i've delineated what i
consider to be ten primal ones so
obviously
and for you know self-evident reasons
i'm not gonna list them all here because
it's part of my book
but the one that i just gave is probably
the most common which is not feeling
like we're enough
and that can manifest in different ways
like i'm not pretty enough smart enough
rich enough
you know thin enough um whatever it is
sexual enough like that whole domain of
not enoughness
is itself um a dis-ease
that human beings uh all can relate to
and many people are defined by so
helping people to transcend that and see
that it's just a piece of code it's not
a truth it's something that you've got
evidence for
based on the way that you're brought up
as i said using dave and his older
sibling it could be somebody who wasn't
picked for the
footy team or you know the hockey team
or
you know or the first time they went on
a date and they really felt like they
were attracted to someone they never
heard back from them
and they've used that external evidence
uh
as a means of triggering an internal
dialogue that i would assert they
actually arrived with so it wasn't like
something
happened that gave it to you it was
external stimulus was what turned it on
very much like epigenetics
and that's just in the emotional realm
so
then you'll spend the rest of your life
and most part trying to compensate for
that
people pleasing perfectionism you've got
to look sexy you've got to be wealthy
you've got to be thinner
as a way of offsetting the deep-seated
belief that you're not enough in the
first place which only
continues to perpetuate it that's the
madness right of these uh
these compensatory patterns that people
use uh
all they're doing is actually sustaining
the very deep-seated fear that we're
trying to mitigate whoops and then you
wonder why people need to drink so much
yeah it's a self-fulfilling prophecy in
that way right yeah yeah
every time that you do it even if you
fix the problem
even if you spend enough time to do the
thing to make the thing happen or not
happen that you were afraid of happening
or not happening
even if you do that it's still
reinforcing i
am the sort of person who dot dot dot
needs to do this in order to make the
situation feel
good to feel loved to feel sufficient
yeah it's um it doesn't surprise me that
people get into adulthood and they have
these
unexamined challenges in life
yeah i mean there's just the mirror fill
in the blank of like what do people deal
with right like that
whole umbrella of what we could call
suffering
i mean the the usual suspects uh like
anxiety depression sleeplessness
addiction
relationship woes lack of finances
disease is a huge one you know the body
starts to manifest over time the chronic
internal sense of absence of ease
and that's going to affect some sort of
tissue system over time
it's just what people call life nowadays
you know and it becomes normalized in my
world it's not normal at all it's very
unnatural actually
for people to be suffering so pain is
one thing you know if you
you fall over you scuff your knee you
put you know
kick that coffee table accidentally with
your toe or maybe not accidentally you
know you're pissed
it's gonna hurt that's pain but
suffering as it relates to the
psychological and emotional state of the
human being to me
is optional once you understand these
deep-seated patterns and that makes for
a very different experience of being
human and
would certainly make for a very
different world than the one that we
currently live in
how do people step into the narrative
loop of how they see themselves
it's just this recursive echo chamber of
your own thoughts in your own head
this problem this problem this problem
how do people start a break point in
that
listen learn to listen
you know if you're with one of your
mates girlfriend you know family member
your sister your mom
it doesn't really matter if someone's
struggling with something
as an observer of their experience we
tend to come
naturally hopefully from a position of
love and compassion and
we want to make a difference we want to
oh it's okay a mother certainly with a
child who's fallen over they're crying
or they're
upset because they didn't get picked for
a team or they
they're hungry and they're cranky we
hold space for that person naturally
if your friend's struggling with
something they've gone through a break
up you're like ah it's all right mate
you know don't worry we'll figure it out
like the energy that we bring to that is
love and compassion there's a holding
when it comes to our own dialogue we
tend to berate the [ __ ] out of ourselves
so listen is the first place you know um
i did a uh live during the whole covert
thing and the
the girl who was hosting it said you
know gosh i've got to
i've got to talk better to myself you
know to her point about her own
sort of negative dialogue i said
actually what about if you just listen
better to yourself and it really was
like in that moment you could see that
she really was like oh my gosh i never
looked at it like that
so if we understand like we were saying
earlier these things are habituated
meaning your conditioning from your
subconscious is just arising
by virtue of the container that you're
in through no fault of your own
then that dialogue is it's already there
it's too late
right like it's already risen and the
conversations that we have in our head
that's a byproduct of whatever construct
you're still stuck in
so it's really about listening to wow
like
i really am quite awful to myself the
the conversation that's going on in my
head
is really quite derogatory and
if it was a friend of yours speaking
that way about themselves
your tendency would be to like make me
no
you that's not you you know you're
amazing and
you know unless it was a guy who cut you
in traffic and then you're like no you
are a dick
[Laughter]
so having more love and compassion for
self
but through the facility of listening to
the thoughts versus
being the thoughts that the trouble is
with an individual is that the thoughts
arise in our head they're so close to us
listening to somebody else is this
illusion of space right it's much easier
to feel
like removed from their situation or
their narrative
but when we're sitting in the you know
car by ourselves we're in the shower
we're just about to go to bed
wherever we are usually by ourselves
there's this dialogue and it feels like
that's me that's
that that voice in my head that's who i
am
and it's really not it's inherited it's
something that you've learned
over time uh to just believe to be the
self
instead of like what if that was like
this you know
mildly annoying roommate you have
and if you could look at it through that
lens and go well what was my roommates
talking about now
um and that's that would at least start
to spark
the uh listening facility faculty of a
human
just then you can investigate the
validity of what you're listening to
is it really true like one of the very
sort of quick tips i tell people is put
a question mark at the end of everything
that you hear in your head
just put a question mark you're a
[ __ ] idiot you're a [ __ ] idiot
i mean it still might be a yes but
i don't know but at least you get to
have a conversation about it versus it's
just a bold statement you know
i really like the idea of trying to
create that space trying to create that
third-party perspective between you and
your thoughts
it took me man i must have first heard
you are not your thoughts on some
pithy instagram quote probably like
eight years ago in between a funny cat
video and a booty picture
and um it's taken me it honestly took me
until
a couple of years ago to really really
genuinely understand and truly inculcate
that i'm not that the voice that appears
in your head
is no more you than the voice that you
peter crone are giving to everybody
that's listening right now
it's not it's just this
this bizarre conglomeration of
things that are happening now and things
that have happened in the past and it
just
pops up and you totally write you should
question absolutely
everything that your mind says because
you don't know
what you're going to think next i don't
know what i'm going to think next any
more than i know what you're going to
say next
when you genuinely realize that you
think oh god well i mean
i mean that means maybe that i shouldn't
have quite so much faith and trust
in the words that appear in my own sort
of mental landscape
yeah that then to me what that pulls for
and what it elicits is the
the ability to observe like it's almost
like a fascination a curiosity that that
inspires right versus it's a factual
gospel
dialogue that i'm hearing in my head
it's like well i'm kind of curious to
see what crap i'm going to come up with
today
see what like garbage narrative like i
can
um you know pay attention today and see
if i can transcend that right
i mean most people buy straight into it
and that defines their
emotional state and then you know if
their mind is telling them like you're
useless what's the point then there's
going to be an apathy and a resignation
and a lethargy in their body and then
they're not going to take action
versus like you know i had a beautiful
group of seven women at my house
as a sort of a retreat event and you
know one of the
women there they're all well to do
they've got resources they're educated
they're smart
was really caught in this world of
playing the second fiddle you know like
for her she was just not
that special but there's no there's no
evidence for that like in reality other
than whatever she would attribute
to that narrative right oh well because
of this and because of that like
she's using circumstantial evidence to
confirm a narrative that is completely
debilitating for her and i said well
what if i told you you were the most
important person on the planet
and i mean you look at her eyes like you
know just the idea of
stepping into that arena that
conversation
no more true than the one that she's not
very special but boy does it give a
entirely different experience of herself
now to begin with she said god that'd be
so uncomfortable
well it's only uncomfortable relative to
what you've become accustomed to which
is that you you know
no one gives a [ __ ] about you yeah do
you want the familiar
the familiar hateful discomfort of
self-loathing or do you want the new
scary discomfort of being the person in
the center of the stage
yeah and and for her is using that it's
not that everybody needs to be center
stage but like to use it
purely as a point of comparison if
you were the most important person on
the planet like literally like that's a
statement of fact not like i'm just
having fun
like how would you feel like you could
see the intrepidation but the mild
excitement
and for her was sort of around the arena
of relationships like you know for her
to be not that special and then she
wondered why she's single it's like well
hello
you know it's like it's simple physics
right but if you're the most important
person on the planet
you're going to have suitors left right
and center just by virtue of the shift
in your own frequency and your own
energy which you're going to give rise
to the people that you attract
not because you're going to be walking
around from a position of arrogance like
she would never get there because
she was too familiar in her own sense of
inadequacy
but just to be able to nudge the needle
into a place of some semblance of
self-worth
that would then be the precursor to men
being attracted to her versus like
energetically
yeah just the way she just holds herself
her body you know it's a little bit like
she's cowering and
the way she dresses and you know all of
that is an extension of her own dialogue
so you change the narrative
that is physics you now have a different
vibratory state you function from a
different frequency you think
differently
you feel differently you act differently
and consequently you get different
results i mean it just
it works every time the way that we
interpret as well right
because the same situation could be
experienced by two different people
and the frame that they go into that
experience with they could
have completely completely differing
results someone could not get the job
in a particular job application and come
out of it and think you know what it is
i did everything there i nailed it
i absolutely nailed it gave it my all it
just wasn't my day
that different version of a different
person
would come in and say you know it was
because i wasn't enough of this or i
should have done more of that or
whatever it might be
so we actively seek for
evidence in the external world that
proves to us the predetermined narrative
that we decided to go into the exchange
with in any case
so it's almost like it's unfalsifiable
in a way
any contrary evidence to what it was
that we wanted or we predicted was going
to happen
is going to be discounted because that's
impostor syndrome right that's when you
say oh
no no no that that was just a fluke or
that doesn't always happen to me
or whatever excuse you want to give it
yeah precisely
um and all of this stuff even if it
isn't true or even if it's super rare
all of the other stuff that's in there
that does confirm the narrative we went
into it with we think oh yeah yeah
that's the that's the true me that's
that that always happens no
you always see that happening not that
always happens you always manage to find
it the needle in the haystack
yeah yeah because the number one
priority
and prerogative of any ego is to be
right
i mean having done this for 20 years it
was just fascinating to me to
consistently see that pattern of like
wow
people would rather be right about their
inadequacies insecurities and their
limitations than actually create the
life that they apparently espouse about
wanting to have and when you see the
madness of that
you really see one of the fundamental
flaws of the ego which is
self-righteousness
right and this is what we see in
relationships like what is one of the
ways that people gone or any sense of
self value is well if i can make
somebody else wrong whether it's
my wife my my kids my my parents you
know my neighbors for the [ __ ] fact
that they haven't trimmed the heads yet
or you know whatever it is you'll find
anything to make someone else wrong
which is
really another means of trying to garner
desperately some sense of self value
we just do it through a narrative which
itself by definition is is limited so
people get to be right consistently i'm
like wow
wow that's you know congratulations
you're right about your insecurities and
your inadequacies that's so
so [ __ ] inspiring you know you've
become
the architect of your own misery yeah
it's the old expression you probably saw
it between your cat videos and your
booties in one another pithy quote of
yours but it says you know you
fight for your limitations and they're
yours right so i remember this with one
of my professional golfers like
i actually ended up canning for him love
the guy we had a lot of success we
tripled his winnings in two years but he
hadn't actually got the win but tripling
somebody's business
you know in two years is significant you
know whatever it is like for him an
average million a year
as a player and we got to 3.5 in our
second year you know that's a that's a
good return
right but you know i remember this one
green we stepped on and hid it in two so
it was a par four like he's
quote unquote you know playing within
the parameter of what you're trying to
accomplish and
anyone who knows golf you want to make
the part and make a birdie
i handed him the pattern he said watch
me three-putt this
so now that's not conscious that's him
being scared because it was a bit of a
tricky part but it's his way of
justifying and offsetting any potential
you know
failure but at least even if he did
three putts it
where he gone as a little bit of sort of
self-pride as i was right about it
even though like that's shitty on a
scorecard it's not going to help us in
the tournament
but that's how subtle yeah how
destructive
the ego can be so it's a it's a
protective it's like a prophylactic
mechanism isn't it
yeah yeah get to be right well done
congratulations i'm so inspired
you're never going to meet anyone no one
loves you and you're a dog [ __ ] at
whatever
your career is like yeah wow how do i
sign up for that
we don't need me the mind architect i
mean clearly you're just like you know
how you don't have millions of people
following your programs
built a sistine chapel of dog turds here
yeah yeah you've got a quote talking
about limitations and stuff you've got a
quote that says life is as difficult as
you are limited
what does that mean um
well it's sort of within the realm of
everything we've discussed which is
i i like to use metaphors i think it
helps people to understand so if
somebody went to a yoga class
and i've gone with many of my athletes
who are extraordinary athletes in their
field but
you know they've never been to yoga or
they've rarely been and so we're back to
the sistine chapel of dog ship which is
their practice and they're like wow this
is so difficult i'm like no it's not
difficult you're just stiff
so it reveals their constraints
right and likewise for myself it's not
like i'm some sort of handy bendy go
you know candy yogi like you know i've
got tight shoulders from whatever i do
and like my hamstrings and so that
reveals equally my constraints
through the practice of yoga but
obviously the more you practice it the
more you can expand
so likewise with the mind you're going
to be
triggered you know or you're going to
see your quote
tight hamstrings emotionally and
mentally where you have some constraint
so then life appears difficult
it's not difficult it's just you're
looking through a lens of inadequacy
for somebody who doesn't have that lens
the same circumstance occurs as either
easy or an opportunity
so external can be the same but as you
were saying earlier two
three five five million minds are going
to have a different interpretation based
on their quote-unquote mental
flexibility
so for me you know one of my favorite
quotes to myself is can i be with this
which for those people aren't so
familiar with my work it's maybe sort of
a
an uncommon series of words and it might
sound a little poetic or esoteric but
what i'm really saying is
whatever's unfolding whatever the
circumstance that i'm being presented
with can i be with it without being
quote
emotionally triggered or affected i
don't slip into frustration anger
disappointment
depression anxiety i'm able to hold
space for
whatever's happening and stay internally
quite centered
so that's again where you know life is
as difficult as you're limited but for
that reason life is the gift to reveal
where we are limited so that life
becomes less difficult because we expand
our quote-unquote perceived limitations
well that's the marcus aurelius and also
the shakespeare
line right which is the universe is
change and life itself
is but what you deem it then two people
can see the same situation in completely
different ways
which means that you can also see the
situation in a completely different way
but yeah there are what i like that
you've brought up there is that
it's it's not as if changing your
subconscious is going to make
all of the situations the outcomes of
the situations necessarily
change you're not going to be better at
yoga by having a better subconscious
that tells you about how not [ __ ] you
are at yoga
but what you are going to be able to do
is see these things as an opportunity
you said it's opportunity or it's going
to be easy
and that's nice that it's not just about
it's not outcome focused it's not
necessarily about whether or not you do
do or don't it's about how you interpret
doing or daunting yeah and there's a
little subtlety in there like you know i
also like
you with you know the shakespeare quote
he said nothing is either good nor bad
only thinking makes it so
right so again that points to the fact
that life is the way it is but then it's
our own interpretation that's going to
give our subjective perspective
but then i would also say that there is
some power
in shifting the subconscious that would
actually elicit
a different response without the
practice of that so
to continue the yoga theme it would
require a proper case study but for
those people who are
internally constrained they went to a
yoga class and we could you know as best
as possible quantified their ability to
do yoga
and then if we did shift their
subconscious it's my assertion that
actually they would be better at yoga
without having practice opening up
because there would be a softness about
them there would be a release
so that's the power i've seen it time
and time again with my athletes
like so many beautiful stories where
without shifting anything to do with
their technique or their profession but
having a different mindset they got an
instantaneous different result
like one of my baseball players hadn't
had a home run for almost the span of an
entire season it was over two seasons
but almost the length of a six-month
season
and he wasn't one of the big hitters who
traditionally get 30 home runs a year or
whatever and he wasn't a small guy who
might get five or six home runs but he
was sort of middle of the pack
15 16 home runs and he hadn't had any
for about five and a half months
again over two seasons and it was
starting to really you know piss him off
and
he's getting paid millions of dollars so
there's a certain degree of pride he's
also getting teased by his teammates
because that's what
you know guys do in a clubhouse or a
locker room
and so literally he was sitting in the
parking lot of the baseball stadium
about two or three
hours before the game calls me i was new
to the sport i mean
i'm obviously a brit like where do we
play baseball yeah there's rounders you
know
and so which i don't know if that even
exists anymore but anyway
um so i'm talking to this guy and i took
him to a place of complete acceptance
like profound acceptance
not only the fact that he hadn't which
is reconciliation of his history because
we're always fighting our past like we
haven't been able to digest something or
accept something
and then that gets superimposed into a
future where we're worried that that's
going to be perpetuated right that's
basically how the brain is functioning
from a place of
prediction and protection we're using
our history to predict something and
then we're trying to protect ourselves
from it not realizing that what actually
doing is perpetuating the history that
we've yet to actually reconcile
that was a lot there if people want to
rewind that and really get that there'll
be a lot of value
anyway he you know suddenly realized
that okay it's what's happened and i
said if you never hit a home run ever
again in your life could you be okay
it's not what we want it's certainly not
what i'm here to help you with
but emotionally could you go you know
what okay that could well be the case
unlikely but i'm gonna find profound
acceptance
we got him to a place where he was
genuinely okay with it
that night second at bat we're playing
saint louis cardinals
boom home run right and and i mean the
text i got from after the game is just
like you know it's like worth the price
of entry in my work it's just so
fun and gratifying to see the
instantaneous results that people get
when there's a shift in mindset
so um and i love i love real life
stories like that where you can see that
when you look through different eyes you
will
immediately see a different world versus
trying to change the world that you
don't like but keeping the same eyes
that's tiring it's very rare that you're
ever going to encounter any sort of
situation in which being more tense
or more uptight or adding pressure to it
is going to help almost never
you know it's easy it's easy to say it
in in yoga where the whole point
of the practice is to be relaxed and to
breathe into the
places and it's quite slow usually and
quite sort of
placid painful but placid but yeah
even if you take mma yeah the fighters
don't want to go in there being
being tense and having applied more
pressure to themselves than they need
they need to be alert
but they want their training to take
over they don't want the front brain to
be too active they just want to be
seeing and feeling and moving and um
yeah the same in baseball as well
yeah any sport uh for sure but we could
say just in life generally
you know i don't know if painful and
placid is like
what you have on your bumble profile or
how girlfriends describe
precisely precisely what i aim for yeah
it is he's painful but placid
right just what every girl's looking for
yeah it's um that you know
physiologically is a reflection of
self-protection isn't it like you know
if someone was to come
running at you there's an instantaneous
primal reaction to brace for impact
right that's the tension
and that's the holding so if we look at
that energy psychologically what's
happening is when positioned
in when we're in a position of any kind
of self-preservation
it may not be overtly obvious but people
internally certainly are going to stay
detention
there's a there's a perceived threat and
that's how most people live their lives
is there's this perceived threat the
boss leaves you a message or
you gotta you know you're late coming
home from the golf course and you know
last time you did that that the
girlfriend or the wife
got upset and you know you're in your
car it's fancy it's got nice leather and
however many cup holders and
you know whatever convinced you to buy
the damn thing and now you're like oh
wow i'm gonna get into
coin quote trouble which would be a
remnant of when i was a child and i was
told off by my dad and
you know it's the same emotional
response but something that's being
created over a future event that hasn't
happened yet
and that that whole cycle is how most
people live their lives you know it's
just like these continual
perceived threats um and it's exhausting
and no wonder the world especially here
in the states is so medicated
so let's say let's say that someone yeah
self-medicated
let's say that someone is attuned to
this people that are listening
i'm blown away constantly by just how
insightful the audience that listens to
this show are i swear that
they inhabit a different part of the
internet to the part that i usually see
on twitter
because the comments section yeah but
just the comments section of my videos
appeared nothing like
the ones that i see anywhere else on
youtube which is awesome so let's say
that as there probably is there's people
that are listening who are mindful
they've got that insight
into a little bit of metacognitions
right they've got a sliver of awareness
into their own programming
yeah what great what next what next they
realize that they have patterns that
aren't serving them
they've got these limitations they're
aware of the limitations
and they want to change yeah what next
help others you know pay it forward um
that that to me is the immediate
response is because
if we were to look at the arc of mastery
most human beings are going to come from
a position
of we start with that which we're
oblivious to
right and that's where we have
compassion we have patience with each
other hopefully to realize that we're
all functioning
within our own limitations most of which
we are completely oblivious to so
um as you become aware of a pattern
maybe through
a series of relationships and you
recognize wow i've had the same
thing show up or in my career and i'm
the consistent theme
so maybe that's a bit of a clue you know
i used to think it was my ex but then it
was the other x and then it's like wait
i'm the one that's in all of those
relationships oh [ __ ]
so then we've become aware of a pattern
that was previously a constraint
so now we're conscious of it and that's
going to take some practice and work to
actually
overcome that pattern so to answer your
question again about your audience being
somewhat you know tapped in and aware
and they've done their own work you know
maybe they're in that space if they're
aware of their patterns and maybe
they've transcended many of them
i would assert they're still going to be
subtle ones you know unless your
audience is able to walk on water and
manifest [ __ ] out of thin air then
there's still work to be done
um because of course i'm doing that
every day but anyway
so the point is the more that we can
help those who are
oblivious we're paying it forward and in
so
doing like any teacher as you teach your
craft
then you become more proficient in it so
that would be the next iteration of
their own evolution is to take you know
obviously where
where you know request it don't do this
[ __ ] unsolicited you're going to meet
with a lot of defense and
self-protection you know
just pointing out people's patterns
without them asking you to
doesn't usually go well so um you know
it's wherever you see the opportunity to
make a difference to help somebody
recognize why they have this tendency to
self-sabotage
that person now is going to be
reinforcing their own insights and
simultaneously
like i do with you you know i use
metaphors and analogies on the fly some
of course i've used before but
oftentimes many of them are just born of
the moment
and so then i'm a beneficiary of my own
mind's capacity
to create an analogy that even i haven't
heard before by virtue of our
conversation
but that only happens if i'm quote you
know here not necessarily helping you
personally but i
am paying forward my insights to society
so so that would be my response is you
know help others once once you can kind
of
to a certain degree get out of your own
way now you get to
have the joy and gratification of
helping others to do the same
you encourage people to ask the question
who would i be
without all of my concerns i really
really love that can you explain why
it's an important question
yeah who would you be in the absence of
your concerns is really an invitation
to look at what becomes available once
we step out of the constraints
in this case of what we've been talking
about the subconscious and it really
appeals to what i would assert is our
innate inherent quality of being a free
being
an unlimited a boundless this is why you
watch movies like limitless with bradley
cooper
or um lucy i think it was with scarlett
johansson you know wherever there's this
sort of
celluloid version of superhumans and
even the whole
like you know superhero movies that we
all like love and have seen
um they appeal to a bigger aspect of
what it means to be human like what is
my potential
and so that question certainly gets a
lot of attention
and it really is inspiring people go wow
gosh like who would i be in the absence
of my concerns
it's really just appealing to and
triggering what i would as uh
is actually our true nature to come
forward you know with the real chris
step forward not the chris is you know
thinking that oh well because of this
and what my dad
said and this but you know this job
didn't work out that i'm
you know i'm an okay guy but i'm kind of
like you know i'm not doing as well as i
could or
that constraint that limitation
is a direct opposition to what i would
assert
is your abundant nature so the question
really just helps to
you know appeal to that deeper sense of
true boundlessness
isn't it bizarre that it feels like
everything that is
in our subconscious that's part of the
source code of who we are
is compelling us to be less than we
could be
if you think about what our genetic
predisposition is even in terms of our
evolution
we're wired towards unsatisfactoriness
we are
wired towards anxiety and threat
response and identification
and then even if you say okay so it's
not it's not technically a blank slate
right you've got you've got things that
are there that are a part of you by
virtue of being the species that you are
and then you arrive in this world and
you spend
the first decade and a half to two
decades to for some people three or four
decades
without really starting to question the
things that you've accumulated along the
way
the people that brought you up the
interactions you had during formative
years and
all the traumas you went through and all
the successes that you went through and
what they told you about who you are
and then you get to this point where you
think right it's time
it's time for me to kind of open up the
hood of this vehicle and and have like a
little bit of a look underneath
and man it is it's a wonder to me that
people find any degree of enlightenment
because there's so much conspiring to
make life
challenging yeah oh no it is and by
taking a look under the hood i'm
assuming at that point in your life like
what you're talking about people get
plastic surgery so
no no although you are you are in la so
i guess that that might be the first
place
that your mind goes to for a reason
i'm just thinking of all the mid-life
crisis and the stupid things that humans
do
like no judgment but like that would not
necessarily happen if to your point they
did discover
what was really going underneath the
hood of like wow i spent four decades
thinking that
i'm useless or i'm worthless um yes it
is
but i would assert you know that's the
beauty of this paradigm of why we're
here as human beings you know
um that is the mechanism by which we get
to evolve and to discover our true
nature is that we need the resistance of
perceived constraint
um it's uh that's the game that we're
here to play as you arrive with your
bucket of fears
life will present you with the
circumstances to trigger them and then
uh the winner so to speak or success is
the person who gets beyond them
um and that's a different way of looking
at the arc of what it means to be human
i've got many
clients who've got more money than time
i've worked with you know a couple of
dozen billionaires over the years and
that doesn't mean that they are by any
stretch of the imagination the most
successful people i've ever met
they could be the most you know hostile
uh angry you know detached lonely
isolated
depressed anxious um as well as anybody
else
and so it's not to be found in this sort
of external material trappings
success to me is the degree to which
you've discovered true inner peace
and freedom so it changes the game so
yes it is at one level bonkers and it's
like well what the hell you know what
are we all doing here and all the
questions that people eventually ask as
you said often times in their
third or fourth decade on the planet but
it's like well
to me it's like you're here to you know
transcend constraint
discover freedom and then inspire others
to do the same
that's the game that i play what other
questions
have you got i really like who would i
be in the absence of my concerns there
anything else that people can use to
meditate on for the next couple of days
i mean the traditional one from ramana
maharshi you know one of my
quote inspirations he was a traditional
indian guru
who would have you know satsang like in
his ashram people would come and
have these dialogues and questions he
was renowned for the question who am i
very simple who am i and the immediate
response most people would be like well
i'm chris you know it's like you know
and
i'm 30 whatever years old and i'll be
like but
if you go a little beyond that like okay
really like
were you born chris or was that given to
you you know what i mean it's like you
come out the womb it's like hey what's
going on everyone i'm chris nice to meet
you
like could i get like some milk or
something from someone's boobie
you know no i mean we had no
quote-unquote labels
right we're being we're sentient we
sleep we eat we poop
like you know there's the process of the
organism but the persona
has yet to be established and so you
look at something like nationality
religion
like that baby the babies that are being
right born right now around the planet
they have no clue about being christian
catholic muslim hindu like that doesn't
it doesn't mean anything you know
so these are the things that get
accumulated over time
so if we can start to question who am i
beyond
the labels that i've accumulated over
time without judgment of the labels but
it just really opens up to a much more
unified perspective
of being human it certainly would
mitigate all of the nonsense
that we see around religious wars and
racism and all of that crap you know
that's just based in pure ignorance and
the fact that people are attached to
their labels and they want to make other
people wrong for their labels it's like
really like that's
that's how intelligent this species is i
mean we're not even close to an advanced
society you know it's like it's just
complete nonsense
so dude other people i i've thought so
much about
how how challenging it would be for any
other civilization that wants to become
space-faring or colonize the galaxy
mm-hmm we don't know much about what
aliens could look like right we don't
know whether they're silicon based or
carbon based we don't know whether they
exist underwater or anything one of the
things that i can almost guarantee you
about any other extraterrestrials is
that their civilization
could not be much more emotionally
charged or an equivalent
than ours right if you turned the
emotional set point
of this species up by another 10
to 15 or something nothing's getting
done
absolutely nothing's getting done when
you think about that i genuinely believe
that it's true
when you think about that you oh my god
we are
close to terminal velocity for
emotionality
of an advanced species that's mental to
realize that
right yeah yeah it's i mean
it's something that i sit and vacillate
a lot just by virtue of the fact that's
how my mind thinks but i look at society
today
and it's you know excuse my friends but
it's [ __ ] embarrassing
you know as a species like the fact that
somebody is going to discern that
because of someone's skin color that
they are in some way
a lesser person whatever the color is
it's black it's you're asian you're
hispanic like like it's just
it just speaks to the absolute pure
ignorance
of the human being and yeah then we have
the audacity to think that we're the
smartest on the food chain it's like
no you you're literally killing the
planet
your own home like i mean look at our
species we harm ourselves
we talked about the dialogue and then
certainly like the dog [ __ ] food that
people put
in their systems the alcohols the drugs
like that's literally poison so you're
harming yourself you harm others whether
it be through verbal
or you know critical uh derogatory and
then even physical
abuse and harm and then we harm our
planet
we got the trifecta of stupidity
right and then you wonder why you can't
[ __ ] have a good relationship
it's like are you kidding me you're a
[ __ ]
i say that with love and compassion and
again i really want to emphasize because
it seems like oh
peter crone like he said no i i'm saying
it as objectively i include myself in
the gamut at one point like i feel like
i'm
doing a good job of like you know
slipping out of the stupidity at least
but you know i i love the old quote of
like oh as human beings we only use 10
of our brain right or whatever it is i'm
like how accurate can even that
statement be
if you're only using 10 in your brain
like
if you're only using 10 percent of brain
then any of the assumptions that arise
out of that limited perspective it's
probably going to be pretty inaccurate
right
so you just see the stupidity of the
vicious cycle by which we
i was going to say function as human
beings but it's really just you know
survive we don't really function
so anyway you know that's you know to
your alien point i always find it funny
as well that like if aliens would even
come and apparently that's going to be
the next narrative in this whole covert
[ __ ] and this new world order or
whatever's going on
like now let's start to get them worried
about aliens and prepa
uh propagate the fear underlying that
you know these
these the madness that's going on as
because they're you know triggering all
of the fear responses
so even in our response to uh an alien
invasion it would be
we would because by virtue of the fact
that we're designed to protect ourselves
it would be a perceived threat
right it's like oh they're bad let's
kill them and you see the movie arrival
right like here's this intelligent
species it will actually try to gift you
a different way of communicating that
gives you an insight into the future
like that's obviously the movie script
but hang on a minute if like these
people have ships and they're around us
and they can fly around
and go through time and they're in
different plan like i'm gonna i'm gonna
make
a pretty confident assertion they're way
smarter than we are
so then how about we just listen instead
of just trying to kill him
right but no it shows again like the guy
that goes to yoga he's tight
okay there's something that you're not
familiar with and it creates
you know the the feared response which
is showing that you're scared
it's a threat right so again it just
shows that as a species
we're functioning in fear and that's why
for the most part everything
is so deleterious in our lives on our
planet and in our relationship so anyway
i got my soapbox there for a minute
because i'm like holy [ __ ] like we are
so unevolved it's like we are so
immature it's ridiculous
we're gods but for the wisdom man that's
it yeah gods but just
shitty gods as daniel schmacktenberger
said peter crone ladies and gentlemen
if uh people want to check out more of
your stuff or keep up to date with what
you're doing
where should they go well i'll be flying
around in spaceships with my new buddies
who've got the intelligence
perfect perfect you can find me uh the
dizzy heights of instagram peter crone
official
uh and then on my website petercrohn.com
so pretty simple and for facebook users
i think i have peter chrome mind
architect
i love it yeah i'm not too unfair with
all that [ __ ]
dude thank you very much for your time
today chris
pleasure to be with you mate really
great conversation i love uh i love the
way that you look at things so great to
be with you
catch you later thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace